nick jonas and priyanka chopra celebrate
mother's day in a special way the couple
took to instagram with the first photo
of their daughter malty marie chopra
jonas
my life is very good right now very
excited the stars are seen holding their
baby girl with a white heart emoji
covering the little one's face
in their captions nick and priyanka
reveal malte spent months in the newborn
intensive care unit they explained quote
after a hundred plus days in the nicu
our little girl is finally home the
couple adds quote while ours was a
challenging few months what becomes
abundantly clear in retrospect is how
precious and perfect every moment is
it's a special thing
nick and priyanka referred to the
experience as a quote roller coaster and
in their message by writing quote our
next chapter begins now and our baby is
truly a badass let's get it m mommy and
daddy love you the update follows
malte's birth announcement in january
when the couple shared another joint
message to instagram quote we are
overjoyed to confirm that we have
welcomed a baby via surrogate we
respectfully ask for privacy during this
special time as we focus on our family
thank you so much
i have a lot of faith in
who my husband is and i know i have a
lot of faith in
the rock that he is for our family and
malty's name pays homage to the
actresses indian heritage
malty in sanskrit means small fragrant
flower or moonlight
there's so many things in march we
learned more about how the duo is
adapting to life as mom and dad et
saurus explained quote nick and priyanka
love being new parents and have been
spending a lot of down time at home you
know you love seeing your
family happy the source added quote
priyanka and nick are private but have
let close friends and family meet their
baby while promoting her film the matrix
resurrections easy learned all about how
she and nick plan to slow down during
the holidays
our big tradition is trying to spend
christmas together
because we're always doing so many
things apart but
just being home with the family that's
all and for the power couple being
together is what matters most
we both
really really respect our
our work ethic and we both know how
important our work is to each other that
it's really important i mean i think for
anyone in any relationship it's really
important to find a partner
that can support your individual
ambition or your individual dreams you
know outside of them
um and and let you do that thing and i
feel like that's the healthiest
relationship
[Music]